agrafeuse stylo scotch le cahier des
modifications la liste d'émargement la
liste des consultations enfin tout le
matériel qui va nous servir à plaisir
depuis deux semaines 42 bureaux de vote
sont actuellement installés afin
d'accueillir les quelques 19500
électeurs inscrits les 20 et 27 juin
prochains tout le personnel communal est
mobilisé d'autant que cette année il
faut également composer avec les
nouvelles mesures sanitaires ont
remparts une par une entrée on ressort
par la sortie sans jamais se croiser
nous avons prévu des masques
éventuellement pour les électeurs qui
pourraient pourrait arriver sans masque
des mesures sanitaires qui rendent le
recrutement des assesseurs plus
compliqué cent soixante personnes sont
nécessaires au bon déroulement des
scrutins
on essaie d'avoir plein d'assesseurs
c'est vraiment vraiment difficile je
pense qu'on va tenir le tenir le sujet
c'est très compliqué c'est des journées
au téléphone pour essayer de de motiver
les gens
deux ans pour éviter les sortants et
entrants
du côté de la plus petite commune de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines avec 2500 un électeur
coignières la charge de travail aussi
est importante pour ces élections
on a besoin quand même de beaucoup de
choses on a besoin d'une dizaine de
tables une trentaine de chaises on a
besoin de deux urnes
la commune de coignières c'est ces deux
bureaux de vote 1 c'est pas 18 bureaux
mais malgré tout sa nécessité quand même
à un travail je dirais très précis
coignard a aussi mis en place les
mesures sanitaires nécessaires contre le
coc vide et pour simplifier les choses
la municipalité a choisi de délocaliser
ses bureaux de vote initialement situé à
la mairie et à l'école bové ils seront
regroupés au gymnase du moulin à vent
ils sont sur le même lieu mais ils
seront distincts pour les électeurs avec
une entrée et une sortie distingue pour
les deux bureaux algie menacé quand même
un espace de plus de 1000 mètres carrés
ça nous donne la possibilité de
regrouper deux bureaux avec nos deux
scrutins dans chaque bureau
donc voilà c'est plus simple aussi d'un
point de vue logistique un côté
assesseurs le maire n'assure pas de
souci particulier
tous les élus et agents de la commune
seront mobilisés reste à savoir aussi
bien à coignières cas plaisir
si les électeurs eux seront au
rendez-vous à voter